après une journée forte en émotions
denis villeneuve a foulé le tapis rouge
de la mostra de venise pour présenter
d'une première partie
tout a commencé avec une arrivée en
bateau le réalisateur était attendu par
une horde de photographes l'acteur
principal de son film simothé chalamet
en a profité pour prendre un bain de
foule
on déménage de l'air
serein pas très bien dormi quel symbiose
avaient installés ensemble à la
conférence de presse il a beaucoup été
question de la symbiose entre le
réalisateur et les vedettes de son film
déjà longue et on plaisante plaisanté
sur saint mais franchement d'avoir une
île tunnel de communication qui tu es
unique pour nous ça ne
c'est ma sueur et protégerait votre fils
est une méga production de près de 200
millions de dollars et un vieux rêve de
denis villeneuve qui à l'adolescence est
devenu obsédé par le livre du même nom
de l'américain frank est morte à venise
il a dit que son rêve s'est réalisé lors
du tournage de la scène du comme jabbar
ton visage s'est littéralement
transformé devant la caméra il ya
quelque chose d'une une charge qui est
sorti et je me suis dit que j'ai à ce
moment je pleurais de joie puis je me
suis à danser derrière la caméra parce
que je me disais ça y est j'ai un film
je suis pas trompé
lors de cette journée deux premiers à
venise des journalistes du monde entier
ont pu voir d'une l'histoire d'une
guerre sans merci entre les atrides il
les a reconnus pour la production de
l'épée gériatrique
le film est spectaculaire avec ces
images tournées en jordanie et ses
effets spéciaux à couper le souffle le
véritable tour de force du réalisateur
est d'avoir réussi à prendre le meilleur
du livre pour rendre l'histoire la plus
palpitante possible sincèrement c'est
pas commun pour moi de dire ça parce que
dans général
du rex que je fais mais je dirais que
c'est un film dont je suis fier il
serait pas qu'ils sont des fours mais je
dirais que j'ai réussi à mettre à
l'écran des images qui me hantait depuis
des décennies il est des moments en
regardant le film qui me viennent me
chercher
qui m'aime beaucoup après venise d'une
première partie sera présenté dans les
cinémas nord américains à compter du 22
octobre les prochaines semaines seront
cruciales pour denis villeneuve car ces
producteurs attend des résultats du
box-office avant de financer la deuxième
partie ici louis philippe ouimet
radio-canada venise